he's the evil mastermind at the Kremlin
to some to others just a clever leader
making the most of a weak hand lady Thor
admire Vladimir Putin he seems able to
run rings around the West winning at
every turn but can he do that forever is
one of his strengths also actually his
greatest weakness and is he ultimately
doomed to fail
[Music]
the key to understanding vannamei
Putin's success lies way back in his
past once a KGB man they say always a
KGB man the dark arts he mastered in
Soviet Russia spy agency have served him
well mozgov qey fooling your enemy
through denial and deception from the
downing of a passenger jet over ukraine
hundreds of passengers are feared dead
after a Malaysian Airlines jet crashes
in Ukraine near the Russian border to
subvert in US democracy she had nothing
to do with me winning Putin has deceived
lied and distracted from the truth to
spread doubts and confusion did he's
pretty sure he and his agents are very
good at it compromise compromise your
enemy Putin's used it to destroy rivals
but his former boss KGB general Oleg
Kalugin says he even has compromising
material or compromise on the US
president and he's not the only one
saying that might explain why Donald
Trump seems to believe the word of the
Russian president over his own spies
I have President Putin he just said it's
not Russia I will say this I don't see
any reason why it would be and the key
to any good spy craft simple charm and
persuasion from Boris Yeltsin to George
W Bush
Putin has fooled one person after
another into trusting him as a KGB
spymaster Vladimir Putin learned success
comes through control he controls
Russia's media totally which means he
controls his own image in all it's fear
our macho manliness
[Music]
he controls elections vetting candidates
and stuffing ballot boxes literally and
it controls the streets ruthlessly
putting down protests finally he
controls the people who control the
economy the oligarchs vast wealth comes
at a cost
complete loyalty those who don't play
ball pay for it with years in jail by
the way the CIA estimates putin's own
personal wealth at forty billion dollars
so what helps understand how putin's
been so successful playing what's
actually been a pretty weak hand dam has
come don't change this russia may be
vast but it isn't wealthy it makes about
as much money a year as australia
country half its size with a sixth of
its population it can only afford to
spend a tenth of what America does on
its military and yet Putin's Russia
seems to be dominating which is fifty
warplanes in one airbase Russia has
reached a point where it's calling the
shots in Syria its forces recently
waltzed into bases hastily deserted by
retreating Americans there in 2014
Putin's forces took a chunk out of
neighboring Ukraine seizing Crimea
without firing a shot Russia sends
agents to kill in Britain and gets away
with it except for the expulsion of some
of its diplomats and with his cyber army
Putin has undermined US elections
discord and distrust online across the
West and undermine faith in the
credibility of our media government and
institutions
no wonder they say Putin has played a
blinder does it ever stop but there's a
catch here is Putin's dilemma winning
abroad means he's losing at home because
his foreign policy is isolating Russia
crippling its economy he promised
Russians an economic miracle instead
their average wage has fallen to just
above $500 a month
lower than Malaysia Lebanon or even Iraq
as you need a next bit of extra money at
the moment it seems difficult but you
will
you gotta go Putin is a pariah no longer
invited too big power summits with other
leaders and international sanctions are
hurting Russians badly you know what
it's led to more of this protest dissent
and unrest Putin is relying increasingly
on repression to keep it under control
but that in turn is stoking more anger
biographers say Vladimir Putin is
haunted by the fate of other leaders
who've been toppled he said to have been
obsessed for instance with the footage
of Libya's Gaddafi being lynched
watching it the gain in a game his
nightmare is the same happening to him
and behind the strut and swagger Putin
has another weakness rooted deep in his
past working in counterintelligence
trades him to trust no one
and eliminate threats it served him well
keeping him securely in power as
Russians thought more and more now about
a time after Putin who can he trust to
take his place and not come after him
and his billions
thank you for your attention and I hope
for your support